this show is brought to you by Blue
Apron Blue Apron sends Gourmet recipes
in all of the fresh ingredients you need
to make them right to your door our
listeners get their first two meals for
free that's right free just go to
blueapron.com Joey and start cooking
incredible meals at home with blue apron
that's blueapron.com Joey
this show is also brought to you by
texture
texture is offering our listeners a free
trial right now when you go to
texture.com Joey when you do that you'll
gain immediate entry to all the top
magazines including back issues and
bonus video content
that's right just go to texture.com Joey
right now to get a free trial of the app
texture and the show is brought to you
by meundies.com go to meundies.com Joey
and get 20 off of your first order of
their great underwear socks t-shirts all
of their great products shipping is
always free in the US and Canada and you
can save eight dollars a pair With Me
Andy subscription plans that's me
undies.com Joey
thank you
oh [__]
you bad [__]
Monday
April 4th a little something for the
Jews get up and dance [__] this
is all about you oh [__]
out of respect
listen to that [__] Rhythm right
there again
when black people with black people
listen to that
are you [__] nuts or what
if you're Jewish get up [__]
salute that [__] Flag here in the
office
[__] them all let them know you ain't
[__] around today
you're taking names
making things straight with the [__]
Nazis
let's do this [__] Lisa and here you go
what
you wanna
what's the story there beautiful
[__] Monday April 4th
and here you are another fun-filled
episode of el churcho or what's
happening now all with my main man
Lee's [__] saying how are you
my friend I'm great oh that I love that
hash it's it's a little harsh going down
but it's just nice
like your mom smacked you you get
smacked by your mommy earrings for like
22 [__] minutes like this miserable
[__] my mom didn't do it that much so I
still have vivid memories of like it
used to slow down for me like time used
to slow down the couple of times she got
mad
like I I butt dialed her this weekend
the last time I butt dialed her was when
I was high with you and I just it was
before a podcast and she got pissed so I
was just I was even now I'm about to be
28 I'm still scared of my mom a little a
little bit
you should be it's not like scared but
you respect a judgment and you know
whatever mom's brought your back and
[__] like that so
you should be able to [__] scan a mom
so you follow me [__] what else
you like the hash I like the hash
smootha you worked out this week you
spent the weekend with Mama you have to
brand with me Thursday night pray it was
fun bro it was a lot of [__] fun man
this weekend you know uh
starting to love doing comedy again you
go in your ups and downs like anything
else in life you just go through ups and
downs you do something so much
you take it for granted you know and you
don't realize how lucky we have it that
I'm allowed to write jokes and go up on
stage and [__] around with your people
and smoke pot and take pictures
afterward or whatever it was rough going
out and seeing people this weekend only
people who knew waited and came around
the back
I got a lot of tweets from people who
were pissed off but you're right there
though that's the kind of club that
you're right there I don't want to take
pictures of people on the street cars
are going by that's how people get hit
by [__] cars somebody got hit there
right years ago years ago somebody got
hit out there one night people were
taking pictures and [__] so I'm always
scared to go on that Braya [__]
Boulevard whatever it's called but
besides that it was great some great
people came out dropped off some Mounds
you got a little uh Suavecito shaving
cream a little something from them they
got me hair products but you obviously
go [__] headless not that I'm making
funny enough no I don't mind it at all
you shows to shave your head so uh some
people came down with some great wheat
you know it's just
it's uh it's really nice to be a part of
something nice for once I was always a
part of oh shitty things
and it's always really nice like
like you know somebody was saying the
other they had PTSD and I giggled
leave the house I always expect the
worst [__] to happen so I'm not
disappointed
someone something really nice happens
like those three nights even in the
Green Room even Jack Junior and uh
Johnny Johnny Rock and Tommy Easter came
down Thursday and [__] blew it up for
you told me he's the fancy oh my God
don't comedy for a [__] year I'm
really proud of him because
he lives in his van
and I'm
I like the kid I like the kid a lot and
I'm trying to teach him something from a
different angle
because he's seeing it he's seen that
everybody down there that he's doing
these little open mics with is coming
from a weird angle
the first thing when you choose
any career is to choose the right
attitude going into it it makes it a lot
easier this is from a [__] old beat
up guy
I had so many jobs and so many great
opportunities but I went into a bad
opportunity
I wonder that with bad attitudes
no no I was not negative about the
opportunities I was weak-minded about
the opportunities I never gave them a
chance to Blossom
before you give up on an opportunity
give it a chance to Blossom either in
your direction or the other direction so
you know exactly where you stand before
you really
give up on it you know somebody offers
you a job loading trucks
it's 12 to 9 at night
your girlfriend's miserable because she
doesn't get to see you again it's always
little things like that that you have to
make a decision
you know you know uh
so sometimes I get late
the word isn't lazy I get a complacent
complacent that's why when I first left
the store in 2007 I was very happy
because it gave me a new chapter to come
and it really did it gave me a chapter
of Comedy without the store seven years
was a complete different chapter of
Connie
and I bummed around and I started going
to the haha and I developed this little
act late night because she worked me she
let me work late
and next you know Gabriel called me to
do that show and I was doing Wednesdays
in Brea so there's always something
going on
you know and uh
I don't know you do get complacent about
anything I I get people I know people
drive you know like my friend Timmy was
driving for one he wanted to do
something different you know if you
don't get
I don't ever want anybody to give up on
your dream
but
after a while you have to take your
dream and do different Avenues with it
it's still that same dream but you're
doing different Avenues with it at the
same time I don't want you to give up
like I never gave up
I never gave up I'm not gonna lie nobody
and mentally I never gave up sometimes
on the outer core in 2009 I didn't know
what direction I was taking this before
podcast
and I never really gave up I just
readjusted everything
it's amazing that there's not more you
always hear a life coach or something
like that job Mentor or whatever it is
it's amazing there's not more of it
because that's the entire reason why I
am paying a lot more than I need to
right now to go to this kettlebell class
you told me like buy some kettlebells
and just do them at your house the
reason why I can't do that is because
I'll get complacent in my workout I
won't do that extra set so it's amazing
knowing the situation before you go into
it Lee mhm that's all I ever want people
to know you know why because I went into
so many situations that I know dick
about
and I had to learn the hard way how many
times do I [__] get in your face
about getting into situations that you
know nothing about when you want to get
into that situation before
and because we all do this it's a
Natural Curiosity
to uh you know this going in and I'm so
proud of you for that you can go to
kettlebells on Tuesdays hey man when I
do those kettlebell things I swear to my
mother's grave I put a timer only
and I count them out because I know I'm
only cheating myself but a lot of people
don't know that
a lot of people in my life don't know
that you know we were kids in gym class
and we'd do push-ups and we do 14
instead of 20 and we look when the coach
turned away we only cheat I was the king
of that I was the king king of that oh
my God I would never do any like hard
work why would why would we I'm not even
putting a blame on you why would we
if they're not looking why am I doing
this this is what character's all about
but then when I would when I would say
that my mom especially like the coaches
always look like the coach even if
they're not looking like if they're a
good coach they're looking they'll see
that they know like that's what they
know when you slack off at work your
boss knows that you're on at an early
age you're starting those bad habits
which we all do you don't think I did it
you don't think I did nine Sprints
instead of 13.
you don't think I just sat there and
touched the line when he turned around
I'm [__] lying to you yes I [__]
did of course everyone yeah but then and
you keep doing it it's how long you keep
doing it Lee
you could do it till you're 50 like I
almost did
or one day you could stop when you're 26
like you actually did
I've done it with I appreciate the
compliment I've done it with some things
and it's like you can't do them or with
everything but eventually no the
percentage gets higher okay that's all
you have to keep working for as you get
older if the Sun is getting high for
nine months I walked around the bad mood
because of that [__] book
thank God Gordon came into my life and
eased it out and I got to think about
what I really wanted to write and I read
a bunch of stuff and I said this I don't
like there's books I read 10 pages and I
just throw away like I know when the 10
pages I guess we're not going to get
better than this because I don't like to
stop writing
there's so many things and then I
started doing it and that was the
frustration
once I started doing one two three four
five six sentences a day an outline my
life changed
because I'm working towards a goal
and I never understood that at a young
age boy did it [__] kill me like boy
did it destroy me but then again I
wouldn't be here with you
these are the things you learn along
your life
that I wish most people listen to this
you know there's a lot of people that
your father yells at you and says you're
going to be a bum and your mom says
shitty and you don't listen to them
right that was me with a mom
that was me that's a kid with a safety
net
you know he would get up at 7 30 and
stay in bed till 8 30 smoking cigarettes
I never saw that in my life
he would sit in bed for an hour and
listen to Howard Stern
you know Howard Stern is great but he
ain't putting a dime in your [__]
pocket and you ain't getting nothing
from it that's and you're 20 something a
lot of people that's honestly why I like
this 9 A.M class because I would sit in
on the phone how many times have I been
talking about get out listen the entire
time I tell you what the biggest secret
in life is
get out of the house
nobody ever repeats my jokes Lee
nobody ever beats the stupid [__] I said
but do you know how many times people
come up to me and whisper in my ear amen
thank you for getting me out of the
house nothing good happens on the couch
unless you find change I'm satisfied
with the 35 cents on the you got
nothing I don't care if you go to the
corner and put a newspaper on here
and they believe you're looking for a
job at nine in the morning just do me
that favor for the first week just get
out of the house at night even if you
just go to the corner hit the mailbox
and walk back go right back to sleep
you took a shower you ate you made some
notes you wrote down your goals and you
got up and you walked out I don't give
you home by 10 15.
I don't give a [__] if you're home by 9
15.
as long as you leave the house because
after a while leaving the house catches
on it becomes contagious
and you realize let me go for a walk let
me go for a longer walk let me go for
look at this a pizza brother with a help
wanted sign and here I am walking around
looking for ads let me just start with a
help wanted Pizza job
you accomplished something
absolutely and
you accomplish something and when I get
up now like I had a dream this morning
that you called me at 6 30. I was short
when you called me at like seven that
you would call me oh you did call me but
tell them what I said to you I I I
couldn't remember that's why that's the
one thing about [__] Jews are telling
you to wake up oh yeah
this morning
they called back what'd you would you do
nothing don't worry about nothing
like sometimes when you call me at like
six in the morning I'll have to like
like I'll I'll pay attention to the call
but then as soon as you get off the
phone like I have no idea what he said
everybody does I always said you sleep
and you go no no I was just here
thinking doing emails I know in some of
these things I've woken up 10 million
people in my life on purpose do you
understand why on purpose because I
gotta get them up you gotta get up
[__] you gotta get up but I now
I'm up it's late for me on the weekends
to sleep till 9. that's late there's no
reason and you gotta get her up and you
got a custom people around you to get up
and they'll get up
and they'll see it your way because I
never saw it if I got one thing out of
dinner if I got one thing out of my
mother
he was getting up early to say hello to
the Sun that stupid saying has stayed in
my head
since I was four
she used to throw me I laughed
she used to say oh but patio
that means get to the [__] backyard
we had no backyard
what do you mean you had to go and walk
around yeah get the [__] out of the
house
when I'd be in the bar playing those
stupid pinball games she'd walk over and
take the quarters off and go that's it
enough go out
go walk go get hit by a [__] car do
something but you can't stay here all
afternoon in this Darkness
did when you
first it's it's different because your
mom passed away but when you were away
from that did you ever like to stay home
like cause my mom was like that no and I
rebelled later and say I understood
where she was coming from oh I didn't
once it got down and dirty in my life
is when I found out how important that
those things are when they got down and
dirty you know me Comics I call him
they're not doing nothing
I want you to take a [__] piece of
paper and pencil and write down Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday
and you pick out the open mics pick up
two three four pick out how many numbers
there are and which ones are more
important ones
and you'll know which ones are time
consuming which one you can zip in and
out of I just want you to get off the
couch every night and do a spot
if you're a plum I want you to get up
every night and do a kitchen if you're a
painter go paint the room all these
things add up
you know I used to at night when I quit
High School loser loser Joe Diaz Thief
burglar piece of [__]
I still went to cap class twice a week
from seven to ten at night took
something inside of Plumbing I took a
teeterboro [__] International
Institute
me and Tommy Russo is whatever that is
like you bring people to take class with
you like a vocational school I talk you
into it
I talk people into it he took welding I
took Plumbing we quit after six weeks
but we still went you know what I'm
saying do you understand if it's
available to you yeah take it I just got
something in the mail a month ago from
uh you know I signed up over here for
kids thing at this park North Hollywood
Park I can't walk behind there they have
a bunch of things and I got something
for uh vocational people who are this
age with this type of income you get a
free vocation to talk to you so what you
gotta go apply for a job or somewhat you
gotta sweep somebody's trying to teach
you something go learn it
if you're under the [__] income limit
go learn it I don't I just read this
thing and I know it's not that new but
Starbucks has this thing where they're
giving
I think all employees
tuition reimbursement to like Arizona
State online
which isn't Harvard but free tuition to
get a degree when you're in like we're
just working at Starbucks how amazing is
that you imagine you work 30 40 hours
whatever regularly whatever the rules
are you have to work and then take
classes online
they can't hand it to you any easy
they can't hand it to you any easy but
then again I got to see what what the
what the guidelines are for Starbucks
let me look at I think it was pretty LAX
like when I started I was like now
accepting even part-time employees let
me look
it's just but that's
there was a big story about how a lot of
people say oh
like I had a lot harder when I was
younger College was easier and and and
people young like 20 year olds are
getting [__] for that and what they said
is like something like 70 or 80 of kids
in college now have either part-time or
full-time jobs yeah when they just it
was something like 30 back in the 70s or
80s it's just it's crazy what people
need to do to get with the tuition
knowledge parents are having a hard time
just sending their kids to school my
kids gotta help out a little bit if your
tuition is 20 [__] G's a year Lee you
gotta have them on a little bit and
that's low okay honestly that's low
let's pretend you got a job and you pay
five grand out of ten
a year I can live with that I can live
with that and you should be able to live
with that oh yeah you're not taking
complete school loans I was very lucky
my parents were they got split up so the
deal that we made is we each pay a third
so I got I got there's a lot of kids who
are stuck with the whole thing so I got
very lucky in that respect you get stuck
with these things
and what job to come out to look you
came out and you had a couple of
different options right now you're
creating a position
which I talk about a lot
creating a position is always what
advances the future in this [__]
it's always one it started with one guy
making a [__] iPhone yeah part-time
you know like just
those when you were a kid if you ever
write down how many different things you
did
you know you probably went to ballet you
played people football you played
baseball you joined Nike though you
didn't like Aikido because your friend
Nick went to karate so you went to
karate
from there you wanted to play the guitar
but your friend played the guitar so you
know how to play the bass you did that
all for two years
you know we do all these things then we
shed different things along the way and
we pick up the things that were stronger
you know so if you're a baseball player
by the time you get to high school even
though you lettered even though you
played bitty basketball in 13 or 50 year
old football and Red Raiders you're not
written down the one thing and work on
that correct that that seems like that's
how I how my life went my mom always I
always wanted to stay home all summer
and just like watch TV and I was never
allowed to do that it used to piss me
off she would sign me up for stuff and
in high school remember I got signed up
I hated it when I was there but looking
back it was probably her I signed up for
the only two video classes at this
Vocational High School in the town next
to me at a summer camp for kids
like and that's honestly yeah that is
how that was the summer before high
school wow that's great I never thought
about this that's a summer before high
school and then starting freshman year I
took every video class they were they
ever gave and
and yeah wow okay summer camp
the more I learned how to speak English
the less television I watched
so by the time I was nine or ten my
television skills were very limited
I couldn't wait to get out and talk
English
I couldn't wait okay okay I couldn't
wait to get out and see a new word
you know at that time I was putting
words together in my head I Remember by
the second grade I had to learn pretty
good English I was getting good grades I
could I was taking aptitude tests and
passing them
but I couldn't wait it was different for
me because I couldn't wait to go outside
and speak English
I couldn't wait for those things you
know TV really was when I think in the
first and second grade before I got like
a little after I got hit in a little had
a little lunch box before I went to
karate was the only time I would stay at
home
I would go home eat like a sandwich and
do a little homework and then I would
get walked to karate three or four days
a week on the upper west side
so I was always one of those guys that
I've watched TV but it didn't dominate
me oh I loved it as I got older you know
then it came at a time when I got
settled and I watched The Honeymooners
and but that was at night
that was after 10 30. I never really got
myself into then I watched Sanford and
Son
Fridays at eight and nine that was a
certain time period for me and I watched
Chico and the Man but that wasn't going
to happen every night of my life I would
watch welcome back Connor or uh there
was a movie on the I think on the other
night the white something white shadow
it was a show on CBS about a white coach
of the black basketball team so I
definitely watched that because I was
into basketball and I want to go to
college so I want to see what the
lifestyle was like was it you just not
liking TV or was it like a rule from
your mom
I think it was a combination
of three things
even at an early age I like television
but I don't like the control
what do you mean I didn't like the
control it had over me I didn't like
that there was times I would sit in
front of that TV for three hours oh easy
that's why I hated Star Trek and I
turned it off at six o'clock and I go do
something else
like I just hated it the more I did it I
hate it and even today I come home I'm
doing a bunch of a couple things and my
wife is in the living room working she's
got the TV on listening to CNN or
whatever and sometimes I'll sit down but
the most I could sit on the daytime is
maybe 15 minutes
so I won't watch anything I'll just sit
there having a conversation with her
thinking about my next move
but I'm really against that
I'm against a lot of things that have
held adults back on over the years
when an adult talks to me about The
Simpsons I get very aggravated
when an adult you know I really do
because these are things that hold when
I see two adults talking about The
Simpsons I want to stab all [__]
three of them but this is me do I hate
The Simpsons no
but this is just me there's so many you
know these super [__] hero movies
they're eating my insides out they're
eating my insides out
but why does the subject matter like for
example so why is it okay to go see
because you're an adult after 11 you
take the hat off with the [__]
propeller and that's it with the [__]
superheroes that's it okay there's no
more towel around your neck well how old
are you when you realize the towel
doesn't work around your [__] neck
about 12 sure that's it that's it that's
it that's it we live in a society now
that there's adults going to see [__]
you know when that theater happened that
shooting
and those parents were there with their
baby
at the Batman shooting in the country I
would have pulled them out and shot them
both in the [__] had his parents
because that's the best thing I could
have done to those two [__] scumbags
okay that's the best thing I could have
done so the both of you is go to see
Batman on a midnight [__] showing
with a newborn [__] child this is why
I don't like those [__] dumb movies I
wouldn't go see Batman versus [__]
Superman if you [__] paid me after
the first Batman there's no more reason
to keep making Batmans and suckers to
keep going and see him Spider-Man same
[__] thing I can't see this [__] I
can't see adults going to see this [__]
it destroys my [__] insides Okay you
Okay Joey but you went to see karate
movies yeah I was 13. and once I was 13
I realized people can't [__] fly no
more people just can't jump off the
floor and throw a 20 a sidekick at 22
[__] feet I saw a movie one time when
I had a treasure chest and he threw it
up in the air and all of a sudden he
landed on top of mountain he caught the
treasure chest there's no reason to
watch that anymore that's how how it
worked in my life
and part of it was I got my light shut
off so I had to decide what was
important and what was not but I'll tell
you right now when some something like
Superman versus Batman or a Deadpool
or something like that does well it
breaks my heart deep down inside
it breaks my [__] heart deep down
inside because it ain't nine-year-olds
with a balloon that are going to see
that
it's [__] dummy adults and every time
they go They're gonna make another one
of those movies when you create those
markets they keep making them they get
worse and worse and more you know 600
million people for Spider-Man versus
Superman and nobody like the [__]
movie Marvel has the their schedule up
until like something like 2020. I know I
saw a graphic about it the other day
it's amazing what about Comic-Con
because that's all I don't think they
have kids there at all listen
oh
I like a celebration of things
how long you know me five years I
haven't gone to one of these weed things
no not that enough
you know how many times Jordan used to
beg me to go to Comic-Con
and sign autographs of The Longest Yard
every year you know how embarrassing it
would be for me to do something like
that or sell shirts
or some posters from some movie and sign
them
how long do you think you'd last
15 minutes
but I know this going in and I knew that
10 years ago going it you know I love
the people who reach out to me and say
hey we're doing this thing and Sam
Bernardino
it's a bong Fest or a reefer fast good
luck you're not going to see me there
you're not going to say anything even if
you're paying me you won't [__] see
me
I don't want to be around that many
people smoking dope I don't want to be a
part of it I believe in smoking a joint
from time to time I don't want to see
400 people bouncing up and down like you
know
I don't want to see that that's a
complete different situation for me
people faking that high and their eyes
are faking their clothes and then
they're giggling like [__] retards
you know
I don't like that either it's it's uh
getting back to kind of what we talked
about the other day we're just cutting
the fat and but the other side of it is
I've been smoking dough for 30 years
I've never acting like that
I've never gone to one of those things
and all the times you've been to my home
you see a magazine with weed on and
everything no you see you post this on
my wall with weed or stickers or
anything like that no but I smoke more
on any mind probably yeah okay
yeah I mean because I go to see the
people when you ski and you see people
all dressed up and ski gear and the
whole [__] thing with the goggles in
this ski for [__] it's like people go
you go see you do comedy they do credits
for 20 minutes they go up there and they
suck
that's why when I do on stage I don't
have no credits it's time to enjoy this
they know I was in movies and stupid
[__] movies and stupid TV shows
you're coming to see a comedian I'm not
going to recite my [__] credits and
to try to impress you with smoke let's
see what you got on stage fat boy
that is interesting different cut I'm
from a different cut I've always made it
difficult on myself because I've always
believed it's a discipline
every part of life that you want to move
forward is a discipline we spoke about
Jon Jones last week the exact time was
11 49 at night or 11 50. the [__] you
doing out at night
God he's happy they didn't check his car
he's happy they didn't do a thousand
things yeah there's reports that the cop
is racist and all this [__] and the cop
was a little picking on him in the
[__] car or whatever but this all
stems from being out after [__] nine
o'clock
you got a wife and two kids what the
[__] you doing now nothing's gonna
happen
that's a mental thing that you gotta go
you know what I'm not going out I'm
going to take this call I'm gonna light
this [__] car on fire and bury in the
[__] desert
I mean that's the least you want when
you're in that supervision is that
[__] type of car so people exactly
know who the [__] you are yeah
go trade it and get two kids and light
that [__] car on fire get a blue one
and a red one I don't know who the [__]
it is you're just a black dude in the
[__] Kia
he hired a driver today do you see that
that's what he said big [__] deal
it's too late now
because now he's got that one strike
against him that means the next one he
gets locked up
this could have all been avoided
yeah just this could have been avoided
he's looking at you know you look at the
fighting potential you look at all the
[__] he's got going on on top of that he
loses Millions for his family
my God no no nothing don't do nothing
you go right from the [__] ring right
to your shower you take a shot you don't
even do the press conference why you
don't like Dana then I don't like you oh
you got to assume that
yeah I mean he must be pissed at him
right no it's not pissed everybody's
disappointed but I'm not disappointed in
John Jones I'm disappointed that he
doesn't have somebody in this corner
saying listen
after nine o'clock that said take that
[__] car and shoot it give it to
somebody give it to a black school but
how would you react if someone told you
that what no like if someone came to you
today guess what what you never have to
tell me that
why because in all that time I got
probation violations for snorting blow
not for being out and I forgot I never
got pulled over I never got involved in
a fight you wouldn't see me after nine
o'clock when I was on probation
but don't you think Jon Jones probably
thinks he's doing just as well
like he's just a girl that out to get me
well let me have to get them since day
one in this cocaine mind
they're always people always have to get
you when you're on cocaine okay and and
the and the fumes of those feelings
linger forever
because I haven't done a line of coke in
nine years and I still feel sometimes
that people ought to get me do you think
that stems from all your cocaine
absolutely that wasn't there before no
absolutely it was it's always there
it's always there but that's sort of
thinking over the years then makes it
become a permanent Scar and a permanent
way of thought it's like doing a an arm
bar a thousand times you get muscle
memory Ronda Rousey can get your penguin
and your pinky and do an arm bar on you
it's the same thing if you do it to your
mind
if you keep telling your mind you're a
piece of [__] you're going to be a piece
of [__] all your life
I do that constantly I think everybody's
mad at me forever for anything if
someone doesn't reply to something or
I'll have when I'm at home I'll give
Paul on my phone sometimes and show the
short text be like was that rude and
she's like no they just they're just not
responding yet I always think someone's
mad at me I have no idea why I'm the
same way and I love it
it drives me nuts why do you love it
because then you think of the situation
you think of why they're mad at you
and sometimes they're not even matter
yeah most of the time they're not they
just got stuff going on in their lives
but it's amazing to see where your mind
goes mine goes to the worst most evil
the worst [__] things
oh my God it's terrible like I'm trying
to work on it and I can talk to myself I
can talk myself down and be like yeah
you all worried your wife was mad at you
yeah well yeah yeah she's mad at me
she's mad at me she didn't like the way
I talked to him on the phone she's mad
at me she wasn't Mellie no yeah
always happens it always happens and
it's not even just hurts it's it's you
it's it's Steve Simone it's anybody
sometimes you ask me you mad at me not
at all I just answer the phone I'm doing
a thousand things and
your family so I can pay to go [__]
yourself let me call you back in two
[__] minutes I don't have to play a
facade with you there's nothing worse
than you're doing something and somebody
calls you you have to take that call now
when you're doing a thousand things and
he knows you're not focusing and you
know you're not focusing and you know
you're trying to type somebody called me
today and I was at the end of a [__]
paragraph
and I had to get the phone because he
had already called me last night and I
was sleeping
so I had to get the phone so I just
picked it up I go hold on one second I
finished that [__] paragraph when I
got back on I'm sorry Doug but you
caught me in the middle of something I
didn't want you to think I was being
rude to you right and and he would and
he knows you're busy so he probably
wouldn't have even he would have
understood if you called him back in 20
minutes listen you don't want somebody
calling you twice unless you [__]
hate that guts I don't want you to think
that to come avoiding you sometimes and
sometimes you just can't pick up the
phone when that I have three people in
my life
that call me that's the worst [__]
time like if they [__] call I'm
[__] doing something
you know it never failed it never fails
for me it never fails if I leave my
phone in upstairs and I leave for two
hours and I come back
I can tell that person is always
if I'm carrying groceries that person's
gonna call as I'm walking into an office
for a dental
a [__] checkup blood work or whatever
that phone rings I know it's that person
Jesus it's amazing it's a and if they
call five minutes [__] early
they'd be fine
they'd be fine and they piss me off when
they don't answer the phone when I call
them back
like when I call you in the morning you
don't pick up the [__] phone and then
you bombard me at six and everybody else
is calling me I want to choke you
because I called you a [__] hours ago
you're gonna call me now at six when you
know it's my busy [__] time five to
seven is home run time for more ways
than one the baby's on fire
the baby's off I used to be that agent
used to call and [__] and tell your
audition no no yeah nobody calls me for
business the baby's on fire so unless
you want to hear chit chat with a child
yelling at you don't [__] call my
house don't call and talk to me between
five and seven same thing for [__]
seven to [__] ten I'm walking the
baby to school I'm not gonna pick up the
phone to talk to you not at all not even
if it's my age
because I'm walking on the street
and you have to pay attention I gotta
pay attention I got my child with me I
got no time to look into a [__] phone
and play dilly dally with somebody
in fact I don't even take the phone when
I walk the kid to school because I'm
with my wife and the kid I don't give a
[__] unless you get hit by a [__] car
it's got nothing to do with me I know
you're home so I don't give a [__] where
the world is right it's scary it's scary
how much attachment we have to our
phones our friend Becky that is why I
leave the phone at home right Becky our
friend works at a flotation place and I
was thinking about going and she's like
okay it's about between an hour and 90
minutes I was like
I couldn't what if Joey called between
like no no like an hour is perfect right
an hour something to wait but you could
call your mom and go home I'm going into
something for two hours don't [__]
drop dead on me and you call your dad
and say don't drop down and if you hear
the phone ringing in the other room you
know it's some Joe jerk off calling you
and would you follow me so I know what
time people gonna call me listen
my agents don't get in till 9 15 9 30.
by that time I'm back
and the other people don't get until 10
10 15. so I have no reason I talk to you
at what time seven it's over
I leave the phone I come here and I
write or I go drink coffee and I Ryan or
I go outside and I write I don't need to
talk to nobody on the phone
I need to talk to nobody on the phone
when I walk into school the phone stays
at home does it really yeah when I go to
Jujitsu yeah I'm with my family what do
I give a [__] what are you gonna call me
and Tommy I don't know what if you like
had an emergency
I don't know you fell in my wife I'm
taking the [__] phone with it okay
I'm gonna take the [__] phone she
taxes she does all that nonsense when I
go to jiu jitsu phone stays in the car
unless it's 90 degrees then it stays at
home
why would I take the phone into my
[__] place of working out for what my
daughter's at school and my wife's got
the phone it's not happening still
if something happens when I get out at
one I'll pick up the [__] phone and
call you back
yeah no I forced myself not to have that
piece of [__] on me somebody was mad at
me this weekend for oh I messaged you on
Facebook number one dog
I ain't got Facebook on my phone because
I really don't give a [__] about it
I got two things on my phone that matter
my personal email and Twitter and I'm
about to drop Twitter really yeah that's
it just do it straight from home just do
it straight from home I don't want to be
on Twitter when I'm out of the house I
don't be anyone
I don't care less about none of that
[__] once I'm about to have Saturdays
and Sundays I don't look at Twitter if
you message me or put one of those
things on my timeline I know it's called
you're in no danger don't bother me on
Saturdays and Sundays I don't even look
into it
that's the discipline so I don't get
controlled by it
I don't want to get controlled by that
dumb [__]
yeah it's
and like how how much you probably don't
but when my internet goes out it's like
it's like world war three no you get the
book and a piece of pen it's even better
for you oh
[Music]
for 30 years I know what it was to get
control because I'm addicted to [__]
uh heavy duty cocaine
I didn't mind that control
that's a subliminal control those little
addictions where you try to make plans
but you don't like people used to call
me right man let's meet tomorrow for
coffee again I don't think that's a good
idea
10 was too early for you I was up but I
was in no mood to talk to you
what time would you be in the mood to
talk to people whenever it was something
to do about cash and how I was gonna get
another package crash a clock cash a
coke at those days I didn't give a [__]
you know
Jesus that's
and now it's completely different like
what do you have now does weed control
your life like that
uh there's nights I have a joint left
10 years ago I'd be going crazy now I
just go [__] it that means I smoke a
bowl tonight A lot of times I don't do
the morning joint because I got no wheat
oh so you used to go crazy because you
didn't have one yeah
once I went to prison
I [__] controlled my weed consumption
and I knew that you could give it up at
any time you know I think last year the
night stops from looking for three
months well yeah and he took edibles but
I broke that mold I still broke that
thing and then I realized that vapor pen
don't do nothing
excuse me I'd do a real Smokey smoking
to get [__] stoned to the girls oh
yeah you really do or the hash yeah it's
different and that's why I used to say
look for a year I've told you to get out
of the house early now
you love it on Monday Wednesdays and
Fridays I can't think that you can't
wait it's a trap
the house is a trap
the house is a trap for you that's why
all these people spend millions of
[__] dollars if you really spend time
you have to look at your schedule like
when you're when you're 20 why do you
think you have roommates
because you go I can sleep in a closet
for 200 hours
but then you go to the kitchen and
there's ants in your food I couldn't
bathroom and there's a piece of [__] in
your toilet and then you see the
limitations in your life and you move up
and you move up and but sometimes you're
like what am I what am I doing I don't
even I'm not even home I'm the type of
guy I don't like being home
I like me at home I just don't like
being trapped
I like getting Sun
you know sitting outside under a tree
writing is completely different than
writing in your notebook
writing in your room writing in an
office
you know typing on a computer in an
office and writing long hand
outside under the sun is two different
[__] worlds
two different energies two different
it's amazing what happens to you would
you be as funny if you had to write an
inside if you couldn't listen to that I
could write anywhere because I I smoked
dope but what I'm saying is the
comparisons of energy okay it's like
sometimes I like to go to jiu jitsu but
there's some days I stepped outside the
house I'm like I'm not going to Jujitsu
I'm gonna go to North Hollywood Park and
do 10 sets of ten kettlebell swings and
a couple queens and a couple squats I'm
gonna walk around one time and get this
vitamin [__] day that God's given us
sometimes the Kettlebell guy has us do
uh the teacher Dave has us do some
workouts outside outside and every once
in a while I'm like come God damn we're
planning to be inside it's cold out here
I'm outside in front of people it's
sunny out yeah Sun's shiny you know it's
nice to mix it up a little bit that's
why some I never liked hiking you know
hiking is just walking up a [__] hell
with a stick and a sweater around like a
jerk off today what you [__] talking
about you took a walk up a [__] Hill
no
no I can't see that either well it's
more of a movement you know get Burly
and going up there with a bunch of
people the girls dress a certain way
have you ever been up there no have you
taken a walk up there no
listen you've never seen La sheep until
you go up there I've heard it one time
in 1997.
okay and a girl I used to date then
was one of these dumb [__] that used to
like all that dumb [__] you have to walk
and they say what are you [__]
talking about I started blowing ate your
ass till six in the morning you want to
go for a [__] walk
first off you gotta walk up [__] you
know six blocks of city streets
you didn't know that right you gotta
walked all uphill from Sunset all the
way the [__] up up there then once you
get up there you walk in
and now it's not like that no more that
used to be a dog park where [__]
[__] does yoga yeah yoga Steve does
yoga there there used to be a dog park
when I got there
so when you're doing downward dog you're
sniffing some [__] dog fertilizers
and [__] all right then there was a
table there there was a couple tables
there
I had just gotten it I had just gotten
here in 1998
1997. I didn't know what
what was what I just kept my mouth shut
and looked around
and I remember being up there like I
think I went up there maybe three times
and all three times
was the same batch of stupid [__]
chicks sitting at a desk like a picnic
area uh-huh
three tables and sometimes it was one
table of and one time was two but it was
the one batch of the same goofy ones
and you could tell either they had
snorted blow till midnight or they would
have done Coke and then they'd go home
and make themselves up to go to Runyon
Park
and they'd wear the hat at the Tony's
the ponytail sticking out of the hat to
really be fake
and they'd sit there at that time when I
moved here what was hot that movie
Titanic was hot they were just out and
Leonardo DiCaprio was out every night
and these girls would call them Leo
I remember I had a dog then I mean Carol
had a dog and we'd let the dog loose and
Carol would walk and I'd wait for the
dog
and I could hear these jerko I was
talking about how Leo
had to be over last night it was
tremendous he played music and he was
the DJ and in those days Jack was still
slinging dick Jack Nicholson Jack
Nicholson was still had young chicks 50s
or something yeah well he's 70 now so he
was in his 50s still getting coked up
still having these young they were
talking about Jack when I went to Jack's
last night and they would just sit down
that was it and they would go over their
lines
they would make believe they're
rehearsal in those days there was a lot
of auditions a lot more and all this
table of girls would just sit there I
never read my lines in public though
like just so people could see and they
would be outside and I just stopped
going like that it just wasn't my bag
I couldn't even then I hated that bring
your lines outside and reading them so
people could stop you what are you
reading for oh my God I love Leslie Khan
she's great you know get the [__] out of
my [__] face oh yeah that's terrible
but it is and you said this was gonna
happen
it's nice now could I go to the same
class every day or every every week
and it's always the same people there's
a few people who come in and out but
it's like five or six people who are
always there and I'm getting really
friendly with them so it's on the when
they're not faking when it's not a whole
bunch of Hollywood [__] it's really
cool I'm sure it's happening with you at
Jiu Jitsu now because you've been there
like a month or two right this is
January 4th I'll throw wow okay
last time I went to vmac was January 3rd
on a Sunday take a look take a look and
see if I'm not lying to you I'm gonna
get my dates right because I don't like
bullshitting people
I think that's what it was
all right 2016.
January 3rd was a Sunday there you go I
think right yeah yeah
I went to vmac that Sunday
and I just realized I was with you I
think maybe that's the last time you
went to jiu jitsu no I had broken it up
a couple times and I went one time with
you and I went home
and that whole December was really
disturbed because my Jiu Jitsu was
getting worse
my breathing was getting worse
and
it just wasn't getting nowhere in my Jiu
Jitsu I got really down I didn't tell
nobody
I didn't tell nobody I just went home
and wrote about it like what am I going
to do about this Jujitsu thing
I was having a hard time breathing I
still had the fears you know every time
I went to Jujitsu I still had fear of
what was going to happen
I went online and I was going to go to
Street Sports in Sherman Oaks and try
them out I was going to try out John
Jacques Machado
I was gonna try out Checkmate and
Burbank
there was a couple schools who had a
lunchtime class I realized that I had to
go to class Mondays and Wednesdays for
me to be consistent and I would be eight
times a month
if I stayed in town I would try to catch
the Friday class so that would put me at
10 times a month that would still be
good enough not really good but at least
I'd be a little bit more consistent than
I was doing now
this killed me from like September to
December and I love John butter vmac oh
yeah it's a great place a [__] great
place I love the Kettlebell system but
John didn't have a Monday
and a Tuesday and a Wednesday John had a
Monday and a Wednesday so I didn't know
nothing about nothing I [__] kept
going to John and then some Wednesdays I
would go to hen uh John uh whatever uh
Higgin but for the most part on
Wednesdays I couldn't go over the hill
anymore guys it was killing me I was
leaving at 10 o'clock and not pulling
back up to my house till 1 30 145. oh
yeah they closed your whole day that
kills my whole [__] day you know and
if I was a UFC fighter yeah I'd go to
Higgin Machado but all I'm a fat bastard
I just want to get flexible I just want
to get my cardio going I wanted to get
this fear of being on my back and I knew
I needed to do something consistent
so that January like that last week of
December I wrote out the pieces of paper
where what four schools I was going to
go look at
they did one last thing I called Eddie
Bravo like a man
and I said Eddie
do you mind if I paid for a black belt
to come in at 10 in the morning in
Hollywood or in uh hey Q
and teach
jujitsui said absolutely not
tell you this no you know because I
don't want no [__] Jiu Jitsu jiu
jitsu another one no [__] kettlebells
I don't want no [__] weights I don't
want no [__] motions and I don't want
no [__] strings I just want straight
Jiu Jitsu bro
well he said like that to me and I gotta
be honesty my feelings got hurt
I didn't talk to Eddie for like two or
three days
but I thought about his words
now here's Eddie
he's been to Abu Dhabi he's competing
he's fought for everything he's had you
know nobody liked Eddie because of his
no ghee in his transition and what he
did to Brazilian Jiu Jitsu people got
mad at him do you think that stopped
Daddy no no Eddie kept going and going
and going and going
and what he was telling me in a way that
day was that you know what Cokes Joey as
he calls me
I don't want none of that [__] in my gym
all I want people to do is Jiu-Jitsu and
I thought about that for a minute and I
go wait a second
I'm so [__] scared of jujitsu that if
Lee calls me and says hey let's go
deadlift and do the elliptical I would
not go to Jiu-Jitsu and go do the
elliptical with you I did everything I
could not to do Jiu Jitsu even though I
just went and did the most I could do do
you know what I'm saying what do you
mean by that I was training with you you
said once to me until Sunday and Monday
classes I liked them because we didn't
do much yeah they were and it was a
little bit easier because I was going to
the Tuesday and Thursday day class and
Hassan is [__] a monster he's he's so
flexible and so amazing and he does some
things that I right now just can't can't
do and it was hard it was frustrating
because yeah they wouldn't even the
classes were small and they couldn't
come off but that was but it was they
were small I was getting a lot of
attention it's a great school but it was
just I wasn't at that level and the the
one class that I should have been able
to go to Tuesday nights I couldn't make
it every week 6 45 yeah 6 45 on a
Tuesday and that's it was tough for me
too and I'm living I'm sitting on a
couch with a baby going I should be a
jiu jitsu but I got a [__] family
right I'm not going to the UFC I gotta
figure out a way to do this where it
works for everybody and I profit I was
ready to quit jiu jitsu last December I
was ready to quit Jiu Jitsu I just
didn't know what to do and how to break
it
I didn't want to get on the 101 to go to
Jujitsu I had to go to Jiu-Jitsu
someplace [__] close to me and those
[__] little classes were not working
not that John Bud's a great teacher he
was teaching some great things it just
wasn't working compatically for our body
you know it was me you and Nick that's
it nobody when I was doing that I was
doing that to see if anybody else from
the school would show up on Mondays and
we could show vmac hey we got eight
people showing up I'll pay for this
[__] [__] we got eight people showing
up let's start a [__] class at 11.
let's start a class at 10 30.
but I never I never plateaued
no I was frustrated so one night I
already have my list I'm gonna take a
week off from Jiu Jitsu and figure this
[__] out
and I got a call from Burke Chrysler of
all people and he goes hey man I'm doing
a spot
at [__] Flappers tonight
what are you gonna do
and I ain't going nothing he goes uh why
don't you come to a spot with me I went
down there and I was at the light of
Victory and Magnolia and I look over to
the side and I see Legacy jiu jitsu
and I said that's my friend Alberto
crane like oh I can't go there
this [__] Killer's there again fear
kicked in I went over the [__] Bridge
parked at Flappers went did my son on
the way back I made a u-turn and parked
in front of Alberta School
11 30 at night and I looked in that dog
and I got so intimidated
just looking at the place you pulled in
at 11 30 at night by yourself and looked
into the glass he probably got me on
tape who's that fat guy who looked at
the kickboxer bloodshot eyes yeah you
know this is how scared I am man
and I got back in the corner I'm in the
left and I waited till the next morning
I went on their website
and they had class every day at 12
o'clock
and guess what that told me I have no
more excuses yeah they got me I'd have
timed it it was 13 minutes from my house
I could leave at 20 to [__] 12 and be
there stretch out
and I've been consistent
two to three days a week this is January
4th
I only gave myself six more months doing
Jujitsu I said if I don't get it
together in these next six months by
August I'm quit
and I love it more than I ever have
if I didn't have all that [__] to do
today I would have gone again today
that's my addiction right now
and I'm not losing weight but I'm
getting one like I'm losing you can see
your body's changing yeah my body's
changing I'm baggy and my shirts are
baggier
that I love that that's the same thing
going on with me at this new kettlebell
place it's and you always used to say
that you have to do different things to
to change your body up to trick your
body up and bro I had I've been fat my
whole life so I I had people everybody
would tell me oh you need to do this to
lose weight you need to do that and I
just got great at justing them but not
even not listening at all and you were
always big on can't you do the
elliptical can't just do the elliptical
and I I think the reasoning that's a
good
uh advice but I think the reasoning
behind it is different for fat people
because for me it's not to
to
shock my body it was if I had never done
Jujitsu I would never have done
kettlebells and found something that I
actually and
me enjoying something athletic is never
is not supposed to happen in a million
universes that's not gonna happen but
that's what I think it is is you have to
go out if if I was 300 pounds again I
would tell myself just try a bunch of
different [__] because a lot of places
have the one week free trials
I would just do 10 of those things
because you'll find one thing that you
[__] like and now
me at kettlebells at eight in the
morning doing or at nine in the morning
doing six get-ups and then today we oh
today was killer we did
uh get up then we did clean swing clean
press squat we did that five times on
each side four times
oh Dave's a [__] man he's the best
and it's and that's what I was talking
about earlier like through the third set
I wanted to stop when that was done I
was I was like that would have been a
good workout but because everyone else
was in the class how long his class is
taking you now seriously
35 it changes uh there's 135 no no there
are some that are longer there's some
that are 45 to 50 which are but he he
does some movement stuff every once in a
while which is as hard as [__] like
we'll do push-ups up and down the gym
like these push-up walks
but it's usually between 35 and 40 which
every time I look at my my phone to see
what time it is because it doesn't have
a clock
I'm not disappointed but I'm like oh
this could have gone a little bit longer
and we could have done a couple minutes
that's it oh no I don't I don't have my
phone
no I just have it because because I
don't want my phone overheating the car
that's all put it under your sweater
don't look at it no more oh no I don't
look at ever I'm just saying after the
class oh after the class after when I
get when I'm going to do that and it's
it was cool today because there's a new
girl now she just started she's doing
this for now what you were doing four
weeks ago right not the low man in the
totem pole yeah that's gratifying to a
degree like even for me like when I
first started going to Alberto Crane's
Place Legacy
if I could do the warm-up mm-hmm I was
pretty much happy
like I'm the type of guy that sits a
little gold
so in my mind like I was telling some
the guy who I did drills yesterday I
went to the drill classroom 10 from 11
to 12.
I think I asked me why I got into Jiu
Jitsu and I told him I said when I come
in here I go for little victories
if I could get something in half guard
that's a victory if I can get some money
in never mind the submission the
submission is never even on my mind
right just the position just the
position if I get to that position I did
really well today if I go in there three
days in a row and you're a blue belt and
I can't pass your guard on the fourth
day I pass your guard
I'm doing great I finally figured it out
do you ever celebrate in your head like
yeah yes yes those celebrations make me
strong in all the other aspects of my
life
I know for a fact
this times I'm on stage and because of
what's going on with my Jujitsu
confidence
I might turn to set around where I never
would turn that sun around three or four
years ago
oh so you go along Jujitsu is giving you
confidence because it's making me retain
my guard
in Jiu Jitsu no matter what happens
guess what just go back to your garden
you got this guy now that gives you
another set of opportunities same thing
with comedy if you're blowing it
stand hold your ground
take a deep breath of fresh air they're
not going to say nothing to you keep a
smile on your face keep a breath of
fresh air
and start from scratch and think about
your words all over again
and this is what Jiu Jitsu has been
teaching me it's a shame I learned that
at the age of 50.
the damage I could have done in life
if I would have learned that by the age
of 35 then no matter what what's going
on in your life
retain your guard
hold him by his collar hold his sleeve
and breathe
breathe and all of a sudden
you're right [__] there
well Tony Bennett on a Monday afternoon
we've been talking for a while Lisa yeah
what the [__] guy
foreign
oh someone gave that to us on Final
didn't they
yeah I can't wait to hear that I'm fine
can I bring it with me yes I did oh
that's so cool
yes I did I'm telling you nice people
came this weekend they brought arms
yeah this was uh Jesse
from Brea
and they said there's two cards in here
telling you people [__] came out this
weekend in full force Tony Bennett I
want to be around
I can't look how young he is yeah this
is 1960 South
this has to be 1963. yeah because this
album came out on my birthday really
check it out go ahead Preston is the
name of the album I want to be around
yeah
you think I'll blow smoke up your
[__] Muffler
put me Uncle Joe
when did it come out release date let's
see here I want to be around Tony
Bennett what's the release yeah 18th of
am 63. who the [__] you think you're
dealing with here
huh wow
so the let's see who dropped these off
leave my man thank you for all you do
it's been awesome listening to you
mature and grow with Joey as your guide
haha keep kicking ass with your workouts
I know it sucks from experience but it's
something that will all be worth it
thanks again love Jesse
Torres and then to me they wrote thank
you Jesse been listening to you since
Beauty and the Beast and you remember
you're seeing at the gig in Corona
California with Jeff Garcia thank you
for keeping a real dog
with love Jesse Toto Torres I love you
too let me give you some shout outs to
nugget Farms who dropped off a [__]
tremendous bag of weed David and Kristen
for dropping off the Allman Brothers
Suavecito men's products
dawn of the thread.com Leia Hernandez
Sunny lighting I mean we got some great
people as always Cleo water boxer ookie
[__] spooky my man Leon you know we
got Casablanca Joe we got Joe we got
everybody on there my girl Tracy we got
my girl [__]
see we got everybody you know what I'm
saying so
we have a great group of people it's
awesome what's up brother we have a
great it's it's amazing how like
sometimes when I'm just I don't have
anything to do I'll just go on there and
start talking it's amazing how cool
these people are
you know man uh
you what's that expression you reap what
you sow you know uh when somebody hits
me up on Twitter I can see the way they
hit me up and they're being sarcastic
well they're trying to kick me off my
wrath doesn't mean whatever then I see
them people popping up and that's all
that matters to me we keep in touch from
time to time I know who's there and I
usually have a quick quick nap and just
getting them the [__] out of there you
know they're only going to be around for
five or six [__] days between you
know we still got Cleo water box and
Leon and Constantine rain I mean these
are people that are there they're there
you know Joe uh Kenyon these are people
that have been there for five [__]
years with us banging out Jesse Torres
and I know who they are and every week
we get three more of those [__]
soldiers that they get it they get what
we're trying to do there's no smoking
mirrors there's no goatees we just talk
to you from the [__] car you know
last week I got a lot of emails this
week it's really weird what gets emails
drug addiction spawns emails
friendships we talk about friendship I
got 40 emails really okay and fear those
are our three topics of the show
I think the people get the most out of
when we talk about those subjects you
know I just talked about I'm 53 years
old doing Jiu Jitsu for two years scared
to walk into a jiu jitsu school as a
grown man I bought Coke from the KKK and
I wasn't scared can you imagine not
being you know being that scared
I had to remove all those fears I have
all these [__] fears and I remove
them little by little whether it's the
acupuncture
supposed to go on for a needle for the
[__] uh
allergies they're supposed to take a
drop of blood out those are the ones
that are the worse they won't drop tell
me you're gonna take two tubes and I
won't be able to see for an hour those
are easy when they just pop the [__]
gun but these little one drops I
guarantee the chick he uses a big needle
and I faint I'm gonna have to either go
there tomorrow or the [__] next day
but those are the most uh
uh
those are the three or four heart we
have probably music that are
hard-hitting topics or
but this week I got a lot of people
calling me and send me emails with the
same thing that you had going on
uh not knowing where you stand with
somebody you know
those are the themes I'm just getting
the emails from what do you know you
stand with somebody and how to sustain a
friend you know for that long
uh this morning I called Timmy I called
Roger I called James I called The Villa
back to back to back to back to back
Jesus and these are people I know for 30
years
you know I called him at 5 30 6. Timmy
didn't pick up he called me back but I
was on the phone with James
uh and then I had to leave the [__]
house and go meet those guys to write
and whatnot
but if you want to be a friend if you
want friends you got to be a [__]
friend you got to get out there
you know uh this year we had a birthday
party for me me you my daughter and my
wife you know was I upset no because I
don't go to birthday boys
why the [__] people come to mind I
didn't even tell them about them it
wasn't really a birthday party
you know what you want you'll get
solid [__] people around you if you
act solid you'll get solid people around
you I always have a knock on them
letting [__] know at one point
that I'll die for you if we get down
right now and we start shooting I'll
pull the gun out I'll shoot with you as
long as you don't rap me out
I'll shoot with you you know and once
people know that they're like okay now I
know I gotta act around this guy you
know what I don't want to be around this
guy because I don't want that much
commitment
I don't want that much commitment you
know
when my mom was in a Heyday whenever my
mom made a score hit a number
she would throw people money
and she would always tell me I know and
somebody is acting weird because they
won't take the money because they know
that someday
they're gonna have kept that money back
and they won't want
when I make a score I always try to
identify some money I was trying to do
this I was trying to do that to balance
it out because the Earth always takes
its Vig always remember that dog the
Earth takes is Big whether you want to
or not I like the IRS you pay for
everything in this life
you know I buy you lunch you buy Paula
lunch
right you follow me it all goes down Joe
Rogan buys me lunch
I buy you lunch you buy Paula launch
Paula buys a mother lunch
nothing is free nothing is free and it's
continual and it keeps going and then
suddenly Somebody by my door lunch
and that's how this chain goes you know
somebody needs and they do without you
throw them a hand down I hate when
people know you're broke and they give
you a loan you're not gonna get that
I'll get anybody thrown out of the house
in a week send me an email I'll give you
a step-by-step instruction on that
person will never call you again oh no
if that's what you want
but because I lost somebody
a wife
that I thought at the time was
sacrilegious maybe I wasn't in love with
her as much as I wanted but I always
believed in my heart I would fall in
love with her
I'll teach you how to get rid of
somebody if you want
I'll teach you how to get rid of two
people
but I also teach you how to keep them
I'm [__] hard on my wife man
sometimes me and my wife don't see eye
to eye
but every opportunity I can tell her I
love her and I could do something nice
before I do it
this morning I got up with a problem I
told her what my problem was and she
goes
I was going to take Mercy to the zoo
anyway I'll go to yoga tomorrow and I'll
cover for her on Saturday and that's why
she's my wife and that's all she I'll be
in a casket and she'll still be my wife
because I know how to keep things
together
I could have got up and told her what
she was going to do
like I used to 20 30 years ago
I didn't
she saw what I was doing
she saw that at seven o'clock I was
already ready and [__] out the door
and she goes what's going on with you I
told her
I said I was in a bind I gotta write
this thing I've never done this before
and I really want to do a good job
and if if with the babysitter's watching
her that I got to come over here at 10
30 because she's too crazy for Moana now
crazy oh really yeah I got to be in the
other room at least
to give and then I take her out you know
if I'm gonna get it so I said can you
bail me if that means next Sunday I'm
going to Jujitsu next Monday I'll take
Mercy
I'll take Mercy all day and even though
I want to go to Jujitsu and even though
I want to go see this guy and even
though I gotta go to a weed store I got
a cup of Mercy because that makes my
wife happy
if I'm saying to you so I know how to
keep things together if I know you want
to go see me do comedy I wouldn't have
kept
you've been with her all day I could see
if
she's gonna go home
she wants to go home to do something
with a cousin and come on let's get some
weed let's get some Stars we'll drive on
the 60 I play loud music I'll beeping
people will giggle like [__] on the
way home like we always do when we beep
right you know but
I didn't know about the procedure I knew
nothing I thought you were gonna lose
and I know during the week you don't see
it so if you leave her for four hours
like I said if it was The Comedy Store
and there was like a a a [__] dessert
store in Hollywood that we could stop at
the Jews
[__] Jews the heaps over on uh what's
that that [__] really good place I
took you to where they're Israeli where
they saw machine guns behind the counter
on Sunset oh uh Roma
Aroma they got the [__] dessert see
if we stop over there and get a nice
dessert by the time you go to the studio
city oh Gods right but you know that's
how you do it an hour she could take a
shower read a book but I guess women
don't mind that and she wouldn't mind
the four hours but you're absolutely
right [__] you because I'm leaving five
and not come over I think one whatever
it would have been he was fine with it
she understands but what you were
talking about earlier like put something
out there and you get something back I
did that I stayed home and then Sunday I
had to go uh Steve and I did his podcast
and when I got home she'd clean my whole
place I didn't ask her if she she and
she's not she normally she's clean but
she doesn't do that and I was just like
wow it was like it was and now that made
me happy and I want to do more stuff
yeah it hurts
friendship that you put your dick in
your ass
a Valentine's Day card you know
a friendship is a relationship that you
bang that person
you've exchanged liquids you eat ass you
you exchange meals you know but it's a
friendship plus 3D I didn't know this at
20 [__] five
I was too caught up in that uh not
misogynistic
but that [__] [__] [__] world
might come from that stupid mind that I
had as a 25 year old that machismo
I came from that because that's what I
thought was the attitude that's not the
attitude At All by no [__] means and
that's why as [__] crazy as I am and
as much as I go off on the cable box and
the cats and I'm gonna kill the cat or
whatever My Wife puts up with me because
she knows my heart's in the right place
that's when I got married the first time
so I appreciate that you told me the
truth you know that yeah why oh bro rule
number one
especially with your woman if you like a
wine make a beef where there ain't
nothing
you want to go out of the house right
now I want to pick up something that
particulates her or if you make sure you
go out to see a friend or some stupid
UFC fight sometimes I'm sitting there
with my wife and I go honey you have the
baby do you mind if I go to John Evans
and she'll go no I don't want to see
that fight no shooting John Evans watch
two fights but on the way home I'll stop
making Yum Yum Donuts
so when I walk in I gotta use on a donut
you follow for my wife so she gets it
gets it that's the only way you're going
to come back is you bring your Yum Yum
Donuts but five hours even young dumb so
I'm saving right Yum Yum Donuts can't
bring you back I see some woman's been
sitting there for five first of all
she's been sleeping oh yeah she would
have been asleep but we're in a weird
place where
like when when you're when you first
start dating and I've never lived with a
girl before or ever like whenever
they're there you want to spend all your
time with them but now she's she's
[__] I'm not gonna see her at all
this summer she's studying for the bar
so I like I'm not gonna see her for our
anniversary or my birthday
it was your birthday the 20th how old
you're gonna be 28 I had a panic attack
this weekend thinking about that I I
know that's young and I know there's a
lot of people out there who are like 20.
bro I'm gambling two years away from 30.
fast when you were 21. I met yeah I met
you at I don't know I must have been 23.
and I tell people all the time that for
a while here I was doing a show where I
would come out here and talk about 10
years ago today
10 years ago let me tell you what I was
doing
and I got emails from people going that
was [__] crazy just to let people
know the contrast in your lives
what was I doing what what is it right
now 2016.
so it's March April 4th April Fool I'm
sorry that's how high I got on this show
2006.
right now I was going through one of the
toughest periods of my life
emotionally
I was lost
The Longest Yard had been out almost a
year and all the things that were
supposed to happen did not happen
and it was just [__] traumatizingly
it was traumatized
this was the beginning of
10 years ago right now
this was the beginning of a funk that
lasted till
I had just gotten throat surgery
yeah
I'd just gotten neck surgery the the
ball the fat ball okay I was recovering
I wasn't feeling good about myself I was
not healthy
by no means not even in the ballpark
guys
every time I walked into the doctor's
office they wouldn't let me leave then
until my blood pressure went down they'd
give me the extra medication for me to
walk out
really yeah I was walking around at 180
or 1160 in those days
now I'm walking around at 150 over 80
and after an hour I'll go down to 130.
that's how bad that shape I was 10 years
ago right now March of 2006 if I think
as I
Carlos and Joe had just had their beef
and I didn't stop doing blow till 2007.
so that last year before I stopped doing
blow was my year of just mental I didn't
know what I was gonna do with my wife
me and my girlfriend at the time weren't
doing so well we're at the six year mark
and
we had just gotten into out of a bad
hole and we were going right back into
another Cash Wise
oh no what was happening I got on the
blow and that was from The Longest Yard
money now my resistance had gone up in
the blow so now I was doing 120 at night
a night 120 hours a night on a minimum
four nights a week
that tears into your [__] house jack
oh my god of course it does
that's like 500 a week it's 2 000 a
month
that's without weed
and food and rent
because I was the beginning of my help
so see a lot could happen in 10 [__]
years
you know you were just turning 18. I did
yeah Jesus Christ I was just about to
graduate that's how fast it went if you
close your eyes and go okay
from the time I met Joe Diaz you got a
podcast you shot a documentary
you did [__] Lee's World you did
three sets of t-shirts you started your
own podcast you had a movie podcast with
Ramos you got a girlfriend
that's a lot yeah with a short amount of
time you're done that's a
I said I said yesterday I wish I had
written a journal as a kid I wish I I
wish now I had started a journal when
you and I got together that would have
been amazing
but I got this email from this guy who
said he's and actually you might want to
do it it's a brilliant idea for his twin
Sons he's doing every day he's doing a
journal for them about what they did and
who they saw and what and like and so
like when they're 18 they're gonna get
like their childhood I was like wow
that's
looking back on all that stuff now like
when I started when I thought of 28 I
was like what the [__] are you talking
about
28 I moved here 22 23
just ready to
I don't know do not I don't know what I
was gonna do but now I'm 28 and before
you know it you're 32. oh no
they get 36.
then you remember 40.
then you had 42 and you start having
some [__] doubts you really do
you really [__] do because you figure
40. yeah look at that I didn't even know
a number
42 that was what uh 11 years ago
yeah you start realizing like what
I got married again which I never
thought I would get married again
I mean a lot has happened in 10 years
that in 2006 so that's what you have to
do from time to time
and really rally reevaluate what you
were thinking about like that's scary
even to me to think about it in 2006 I
was not married I did not have a child
in my future a podcast was not even
close to happening there was nobody
coming to my shows there was no Twitter
there was no
nothing that was maybe uh Myspace
and look at what's happened in 10 years
so if you're 26 right now start [__]
thinking start thinking about how fast
this [__] goes man
this is a journey that goes [__] fast
I got back from Paducah last Sunday I
blinked and I was picking her up at the
[__] Airport
she even said the same thing these were
the fastest four [__] Days of Our
Lives
I thought I was in a mission it was
going to be slow it was so [__] busy
it was so [__] busy last week I don't
even know where to start or what end
do you still feel
like what age do you feel
because it just feels to me like kind of
like what you just said it feels to me
like I got here put my head down and
started working and now I'm gonna be 28
in July and it's like what are you
talking about
how old do I feel right now yeah
I feel better now than what I did at 40.
wow
those two years three years was the
longest yard when I was 4 18 I couldn't
go up those stairs at the three floors
and
every time I went to the doctor was a
surprise and there was some scary
[__] issues
I feel better now
you know every time you do 10 push-ups
of that you know now I go I could do the
warm-up at Jiu Jitsu and I think about
me as a 53 year old and the warm-up that
I'm doing and how I'm surviving it and
you know I'm fine I'm gonna be fine
you know age is what you you know if you
surround yourself with old people you're
gonna get old yeah I'm not trying to get
young I'm not doing face jobs I don't
wear young clothes I don't wear young
sneakers I don't do young things I'm an
old [__] man and I accepted it now I
am it's not being old it's staying young
in your mind
it's knowing what the trends are I'm
like a six-year-old in my mind I don't
want people to think that uh
you know I don't want somebody to say to
me do you know what and I'm not keen on
all the computer stuff if it wasn't for
you you know yeah I do the Facebook and
the twitters and [__] like that but I
don't really uh
I'm not keen on like all of them I'm not
really trying that hard to I like to
Twitter it keeps the messages short and
I like the Facebook and we move from
[__] there but if I gotta take
pictures all day and put them up I can't
Snapchat stories yeah I don't want to do
none of that [__] I don't want to do
nothing of that [__] I'm too busy in my
day
who are the sponsors today let's start
with texture I love these [__]
my wife uh just went with the Paducah
and she said the baby fell asleep and
she was very happy that she had
downloaded the texture
because uh she got to read some magazine
or whatever
you know uh it's it's not a bad you know
I don't read that many magazines as much
as I used to but my wife still does so
this is this was always great for her
but she says that they highlight certain
stories so you know listen thanks to
Pizza we all we all binge eating thanks
to Netflix we're all binge watching but
now with texture you can start to binge
read trust me it's all about one thing
when it comes to magazines you know what
you like and the texture you can with
texture you can get all the magazines
you want in one super convenient place
texture has completely reimagined
magazines giving you the Articles and
stories you really want all in one place
plus interactive features videos and
recommendations just for you the texture
app lets you tap into the world's most
popular magazines anywhere anytime using
your smartphone or tablet Breeze through
hundreds of your favorite magazines
including back issues and pick the
articles that interest you the most all
right texture has made it easy
to find articles you care about I don't
just get to read uh
you know Sports Illustrated and uh and
that's the issue because it's hard to
get all those matters it's hard to get
all of them all because you have the
mega fingertips the texture editorial
team recommends content for me every day
plus I could dive deeper into
personalized collections do me a favor
sign up protection right now and gain
Insider access to all the content from
the world's best Publications the best
part textures offer my listeners right
now that means you you folks are free
trial right now when you go to
texture.com Joey you'll gain immediate
entry into all the top magazines
including back issues and bonus video
content start binge reading for free
right now when you go to texture.com
Joey again
that's textured.com Joey the texture app
is entirely digital so it's super
environmentally friendly way to consume
the best magazines and articles again
start binge reading for free right now
when you go to techshit.com
slash Joey how's that for you you
[__] Savages and I'll tell you if my
wife likes it she's a pain in the ass
but if she likes it then uh you'll be
fine all right listen whether you're
wearing suits or sweats you spent almost
24 hours a day in your underwear but
instead of making a statement like
Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes your underwear is probably
boring like mine used to be me on these
changed after me and he's gonna change
it for you too all right every pair of
me on these is made from substantially
Source modal a fabric that's twice as
soft as cotton when I work out this is
all I wear is me on these because it
keeps my balls dry nothing can describe
the FIT and feel of me on these but once
you try them you'll understand why
they're called the world's most
comfortable underwear and if you don't
love your first pair of me undies
they're free no questions asked me on
these is dozens of styles limited
edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear whether
anyone can see them or not you go to
some girl's house you want a sling dick
you got to have nice underways so this
is what I'm gonna do shipping is free in
the US and Canada and you can save up to
eight dollars a pair with me on the
subscription plan get the subscription
or get a single pair get 20 off your
first order when you go to me on
these.com slash Joey again that's me
undies.com Joey for 20 off your first
order me undies.com Joey you're gonna
love these underwear also there's
something I forgot to tell you people
here where's the the texture thing I
have here because I forgot to tell you
people some of the magazines you got on
there with texture
all right you got vegetarian times you
got Woman's Health you got yoga journal
you got Truck Trend you got the New
Yorker you got the essence you got ESPN
magazines you got Men's Health go to
texture.com right now slash Joey also
before I forget one of the favorite
things that we uh highlight here because
whenever they send me a box I tell you
what man I like these I really enjoy the
Blue Apron stuff okay
uh
this week let me just tell what
boyfriend has this week all right
meatball or I go this for the single for
the for the two-person plan meet more
rugged barbecue spiced salmon salad and
for the family plan you got panko
crusted chicken nice Swiss cheeseburgers
and English muffins and Holly garlic cod
with bok choy okay it's okay you can
admit it the last thing anybody wants to
do after work is wait in line at a
grocery store schlep Palm and cook a
complicated meal because you gotta clean
up and all that garbage and I'll tell
you what expensive unhealthy takeout is
hardly better that's what there's a new
service called blueapron.com one of the
first one of my favorite all-time
companies okay and I'll tell you why
because they deliver farm fresh
ingredients and step-by-step recipes
right to my house I'm a [__] [__]
but because of Blue Apron it helps me
create a healthy happy handcrafted meal
at home without going to the grocery
store and for less than ten dollars per
meal you ready ten dollars per meal Blue
Apron sends you fresh ingredients
perfectly proportioned making cooking
healthy meals really easy and fun no
trips to the grocery store and no waste
from unusual ingredients plus this is
the best thing about Blue Apron you
learn to [__] cook
you really learned how to cook and stuff
that you will never you know anybody can
cook a cheeseburger whatever these are
specialty ingredients that are normally
hard to find blue way but it's perfect
for date night if you want a sling dick
cooking with friends and they even offer
a family plan with kid-friendly
ingredients so the whole family can eat
well and have fun preparing the meals
together each balanced meal is 500 to
700 calories per serving and so tasting
you never know cooking takes about a
half hour shipping is flexible and free
and the menus are always new all right
like the one I just told you I mean come
on we're gonna get meatball and panko
crusted chicken plus you learn how to
make that stuff they work around your
schedule and dietary preferences and
blue apron's experts Source only the
best seasonal ingredients for incredible
meals like I said the barbecue spice
salmon or the Swiss cheeseburgers on
English muffins you'll cook incredible
meals and be blown away by the quality
of freshmen all right so do me a favor
Blue Apron is the better way to cook
check out this week's menu and get your
first two meals for free by going to
blueapron.com Joey my treat first two
meals they were on [__] leave the Jew
here when you go to blueapron.com slash
Joey that's how much we love you I've
got another shout out to text you me
undies and blueapron.com all right uh
thank you for watching the show today I
love you [__] with all my heart
I'm gonna be home for a while but uh
helium
where am I gonna be in Buffalo
April 21st and my man crackers in
Indianapolis
April 28th we ain't [__] around I
love you guys another shout out to Lee
all my sponsors texture me on me in blue
apron and for everybody who listened to
the [__] tremendous show today I love
you [__] and we'll be back
Wednesday evening at eight o'clock be
square or whatever the [__] it is stay
black [__]
go to texture.com Joey right now and
they're offering our listeners a free
trial on their brand new app texture
you'll get immediate entry into the all
the top magazines including back issues
and bonus video content that's
texture.com Joey
shows also brought to you by meandies go
to meandies.com Joey right now to get 20
off of your first order of all their
great underwear t-shirts socks
sweatpants all the great products
and shipping is always free in the US
and Canada you can save up to eight
dollars a pair with the Miami
subscription plan that's meandies.com
Joey and go to blueapron.com Blue Apron
sends Gourmet recipes and all the fresh
ingredients you need to make them right
to your door our listeners get their
first two meals for free go to
blueapron.com Joey and start cooking
incredible meals at home with blue apron
that's blueapron.com Joey
foreign